with 7 billion people on earth
it's a wonder that there are still
corners of this planet that remain
untouched
but one man has made it his life's work
to see them no matter what danger the
journey may bring
mike labecky has never been one to shy
away from a challenge
the former national geographic explorer
of the year
has completed major expeditions on all
seven continents
he's a modern day explorer who puts his
life on the line to challenge the idea
of what humans are capable of enduring
his goal
to seek out the earth's last truly
untouched places
i grew up in california about 30 miles
from yosemite national park the center
of the universe for climbing my friend's
older brother's friend happened to take
us out rock climbing one day
totally random i didn't even know what
rock climbing was
and
it changed my life that day
as soon as i came home from my first day
of climbing i was buying climbing rope
climbing shoes harness climb climb climb
that's all i could think about and that
basically evolved into living in
yosemite climbing el capitan and half
dome and i think oh my gosh i could take
this climbing all over the world
the becky's passion for adventure has
taken him around the planet to nearly
100 countries
but he's not content with following
traditional routes
his specialty is bagging first ascents
first ascent is basically climbing a
route or going to the top of a mountain
no one's climbed before so truly going
into parts of the planet that no human
has been to before it really takes every
single thing that you have
i mean these aren't just first ascents
these are the most remote most demanding
first descents and climbs on the planet
there is no rescue possibility we're 100
self-reliant
and i'm not seeking danger or death i'm
seeking the ultimate challenge and the
ultimate mystery of what's out there
from the blistering heat of afghanistan
she got hot quick
to the extreme cold of canada the
weather is getting worse and it is cold
up here the climber turned explorer's
trips have taken him through every
climate
i have thousands of maps downstairs and
it's just constant planning and constant
research
there's an incredible amount of physical
demand i'm carrying 100 pound loads for
80 miles you know climbing these
big walls enduring all the weather and
the environments looks like a storm is
upon us we're a little bit delirious
cold dehydrated you know one of the
things i have to do is train i have to
be physically fit to have this lifestyle
and one of my favorite ways is to train
with my dogs
i have a mother and daughter dog scree
and glacier and they're my favorite
training partners and we get out in the
mountains literally every single day
that i'm home
and you really have to work hard or you
will suffer out there
being an explorer has a lot of
responsibilities it's not just going out
and climbing exploring it's getting
people excited to care more about the
planet and being able to share these
stories without the remote places or
these remote cultures
with 23 more trips in the works
lebecki is likely to reach his goal of
100 expeditions before long i'm
self-diagnosed with oecd and that's
obsessive expedition climbing disorder
it's my fuel of life
i've often thought about when will i
stop going on these expeditions and it's
basically when will the passion stop
i hope it never does because this is a
passion this is what i love this is what
drives me you gotta live a sweet life
[Music]
you